the Comedy Store would like you to know
that the views and opinions expressed on
this podcast are strictly those of the
speakers or authors and do not
necessarily reflect or represent the
views and opinions held by the Comedy
Store and its affiliates
[Music]
in theory do you be our intros are
generally about three to five minutes in
it's like oh wait are we yeah this is
our talk oh yeah we're yeah guys this is
the Comedy Store podcast I think you
figured that out by the fact that we
were talking and didn't tell you what it
was but they know what's going on and
they clicked they did click on it and
start listening we have to trick him
with like 17 crazy death stories and
then they click on it and then our
podcast starts hey guys what's up but at
that point I already hooked that makes
you sound like a magician you know I do
have a headshot the floating floating
around out there that I was like leaning
into the camera and I had a suit and tie
on edit my glare my gaze it looks like a
magician it looks so bad and it's it's
it's probably 10 years ago and it fouls
me for some reason
everywhere I go that's what they pick
off the internet to make a poster out of
just like I would never go see that guy
America disagree America's oh yeah he
might be a magician there might be
comedy and tricks it's on Hulu and
Amazon and epic scenes yeah I have a
show that I wrote for yeah yeah
yeah I I like to go on outlets they're
very difficult to find it depends on
what you're into like the people that
have epics that love epics and but there
those are different from the Hulu people
and the Hulu people look at Amazon
Michael I thought that's where I got my
toothpaste from I do all of them I have
kids I don't watch that much myself
frankly but uh yeah the kids I just you
know they just complain they're like we
don't all right yeah we can't see them
here so just get over how old are your
kids 14 and 11 damn they're already
smarter than me I tried to watch black
mayor I have no idea what was going on
really yeah people do it's good it's uh
it's like a Twilight Zone kind of thing
yeah and then like each episode doesn't
you don't have to see the one before and
now you're totally like the old school
they're all freestanding but a little
you know modern twist to it there's some
really good ones yes I came into an
episode my wife was watching about ten
minutes and I was just like and then
something like can you explain it to
weeks I didn't want her to think I'm
dumber than I clearly AM I just was like
I love this episode almost four years oh
yeah yeah how seven months that's
tougher that's so much tougher wanna you
want to talk [ __ ] you want to lose you
want to write you want to try and lie I
mean come
I'm yeah I'm right there I enjoy it I
enjoy watching you try it's all good
but that age when they didn't you don't
know what they're saying and you have no
and there's no need II just so exhausted
all the time
yeah my wife works so I'm like
stay-at-home dad I don't think I'm good
at all and then you come out at night
and do stand-up yeah that is such a long
way now at this point don't you look at
comedians like Bobby Lee or someone like
that like he just woke up yeah it's 9
o'clock at night he talks about waking
up like 4:00 or 5:00 in the afternoon
I'm like we have four days at your
comedy should be graded on a curve
yeah you should say that every time you
get up there I've been up since I just I
feel like my comedy is dependent on my
level of rage yeah a lot of ways it's
almost like I've been given extra credit
because I just immediately angry the
crowd could be great I'm immediately
just like now you're totally single
right yeah there are seven and 11 that's
so crazy cuz they're adults and cool oh
wow but max was he was like 25 always he
was like the quiet that's great
that's what I liked I kept saying when
the mine was like seven months old and
she's beautiful she's great I can't wait
I can sit in a diner with her yeah I
just have a lunch and talked for a while
yeah that'll be sweet yeah it is sweet
that sounds way better to girls yeah
yeah and I just had
and my my sister-in-law just came down
with her two daughters so there's
literally six women in the house and me
and yeah it really is like when little
you kind of like oh it's not a big deal
so I'm the only guy and at this point
sometimes it's so overwhelming the
estrogen it's just like wow I really
don't belong here but it's kind of
getting stressed out just thinking about
it my mother-in-law and sister-in-law
and niece are all coming to visit from
Israel Oh two weeks and I'm gonna be
overwhelmed I think you know just walk
out for a little while there'll be some
relief for you I hope so
I keep thinking they're just gonna like
give me then denise is one so I'm gonna
have the one-year-old and the seven
month old and I'm assuming they're just
gonna go shopping and I'm gonna be it's
gonna be exhausting yeah but I you know
they definitely do that but the one
thing I've learned to pick up is more
masculine habits and you see why these
classic masculine pursuits have stood
the test of time because it really makes
all the women go away yeah which is like
smoking cigars okay or opening up strong
scotch the smell of strong scotch these
are repellent so you push them away
every girl yeah just walk around the
cigar hang out you're gross and they run
away oh and then just shimmy backyard
like they're not gonna come see them
close the windows into the sliding doors
you're the worst
I'm the best My Mind's already running
like you just start having below and
mud-wrestling whatever it takes I'm
gonna go as pause as everyone though
love my dress yeah
definitely embrace it set her up in the
wrong path
24 years actually yeah 24 years no I was
just thinking uh it'll be 24 years in
June yeah New York yeah was the best I
just started like two years ago I think
Adam brought me in yeah yeah yeah we
made it was one of the things where I
remember like looking at the lineups and
like I'd see new names and I'd be like
oh so until performing here now and then
I'd always give Adam [ __ ] I'm the
[ __ ] he'll go in if I see Adam
watching someone yeah and I'll sit next
to them and then when they tell their
jokes I'll explain to him what the joke
is
would you please shut the [ __ ] up but I
went in when the first time I saw you on
the one who sat there and you're very
funny until I was watching in the
Natomas I I don't think I've ever seen
you not try and ruin someone say oh just
like give me that look like I don't
trust ya he was my friend before you is
the talent coordinator right now it's
like if he like that he's brought in a
lot of guys who are like good comics
yeah but like when he passes a comic
who's like an up-and-coming comic or
whatever and yeah it's just immediate
like well that was the worst decision to
do
and I keep bringing in star power we
don't need to bring in new up-and-coming
comics no but it was it was really cool
because it was it was one of those
places that you know have these growth
spurts and personality changes and you
know I was going to the other clubs a
lot and I would come here every once in
a while and it would be just too weird
would just be a little off-putting it
was like uncomfortable to hang out it
was just it wasn't there's a lack of
professionalism yeah a long time where
it's like what's going on exactly yeah
and there was like the it was just you
know just had a darker mood and and when
he asked me to come this time which i
think was about two years ago yeah it we
just was different it was like oh now
I'm running into people I know and
there's some people like it's just the
vibe was different and and now it is by
far my favorite place to work yeah it's
like a professional club now as opposed
to yeah yeah you know just the dark drug
den right easy that's kind of how was
yeah there's one room open usually and
then just like 30 dark rooms filled with
lottery really it was like one show and
I yeah for like the longest time it was
the main room I don't even know why it
existed wow it's so crazy because you
know it's almost so busy going last
night and I was like I just want to work
on this new stuff you know what I mean I
don't want to come in and have like
Sebastian throwing fast balls and
steeper and throwing so I haven't then
you get up there and kind of stumble
around so cuz then you have to so I'm
like so nice because it was rainy last
night coming up coming up sunset there
was nothing going on there's no
cars I'm like oh this will be perfect
yeah I don't know what he was talking
about everything after Eliza and the
place was packed I could even sit down
before yeah when I was younger I would
rarely got spots here but hang out and
party and so I thought it was great yeah
and now yeah like I'm I don't party at
all anymore right and it's always packed
yeah I have to tie now I'm just like I
just want there to be somewhere I can
hang out and not have to see people this
is actually the most quiet it's been
yeah right now in this room how many
comics did you just one oh Willy Andrew
oh that's when you met up with him like
in below
you snuck in there sweet guy nice guy
nice guy
easy a sweet guy yeah it was very
shocking to me because I had been on
tour with Pauly
it was the worst experience ever of
anyone's life not just mine if an how
long I went with them for like a year
and a half different things like we come
back here weekend in a couple times
where we went to multiple cities right
it was always the worst experience ever
and then then Andrew Sebastian was his
opener yeah he was I can't remember what
it was he was like had an audition or a
callback for a pilot or that TV show
Joey
the French spin-off oh yeah so Sebastian
had to cancel because he was had some
sort of a career going yeah and so dice
asked me if I wanted to go and I went
for a couple weeks with dice and he was
like the nicest experience ever really I
was so shocked how did this yeah and
he's like all friendly and like a good
dad and like this good person
and then he goes on stage and does this
thing and you're like I should not be on
stage more successful said the same
thing out loud I was with Colin Quinn
and I said and it was when Larry the
Cable Guy was really huge like people
don't really like you as you just make a
new you that sounds like pretty good
yeah and I and I this is always like a
bad thing of like having like a real
moment in front of comics he just reads
you and rips you apart yeah but you know
it'd be weird for my fans to be to be
like what's he doing now really you have
that many fans no one knows what you're
doing
no one knows who you are you could be
anything and there some of them are so
good at I mean in Norton and when
Patrice was around and Anthony it was
just like yeah those guys are really
mean and really accurate that's what
makes them so good they're so uncommon
even lying yeah it's like oh I knew I
shouldn't put this shirt on when I came
out I knew the cups or a little too sure
yeah it's bro that's like cool yeah but
Colin doesn't it like a different let
like Colin is like into your psyche yeah
but he completely will take your
personality out he knows exactly what's
bothering you and he doesn't do it too
like he won't cut you down like like the
other guys I can just leave you he'll
just let you know that he knows exactly
what your insecurities oh it's your
brutal yeah you can't say anything
without those guys just revealing but
that's what makes them such great
comedians also they did they have no no
boundaries and always commenting totally
in the moment knew the situation and
themselves yeah and I take themselves
down to so it's not ass yeah just
revealing like look how I'm
pontificating right now about how
comedians are you know they like they
always like on top of it and you kind of
like you forget that sometimes when
you're just talking no no he was he was
yeah I was watching him on remote
control counts really old I I started in
93 and I went to the New York Comedy
Club was my first open mic and when I
walked in the only other comic waiting
to go on was greg Giraldo
just sitting there like sweating so
nervous totally like a little bunny and
I was like hey why are you so nervous
this company
I didn't think I was gonna be nervous
and so I became my class was like
Geraldo Gaffigan myself and the people
who were like right ahead of us were
like Dave Attell and Kevin Brennan and
Louie and that whole crop of people and
at the same time that was when like
Sarah and yeah and and all the mark
Mayer and all those people those were
they were like if they were juniors I
was a freshman like when I came in yeah
that's a good crew
yeah Geraldo and Dorado and Gaffigan we
used to do like little shows at this
place called del sohma's it was like
this little Italian restaurant like
right in the theater district and you'd
go downstair like a really nice Italian
restaurant then you go downstairs it was
like this shimmery like silver curtain
on this little stage and like I guess
some cabaret acts would go in there and
do stuff from time to time and we would
just go down there and do these shows
and yeah it was really great
now they were it was kind of yeah they
were kind of slowing up upstairs and
then we'd go down and do these shows and
kind of crowd during getting for the
show like the friends it was like bring
your shows write our own bring our shows
you know right we're kind of creating it
and yeah no no we would just try and get
an audience I remember putting it in
that much work at that time for that
stuff you know just kind of I was
started hosting at New York at stand-up
New York oh really quickly yeah the guy
there yeah and he put me on stage to
start hosting shows and that that's why
that quickly got me like regular spots
of clubs so I didn't spend a lot of time
doing a lot of open mikes and stuff oh
wow cuz I jumped really quickly and
Gaffigan was weird and quiet and he was
doing like this little character like
you know how he does that little voice
you know there that thing he was doing
that like he hadn't worked it out yet it
was just emerging so it was really weird
straight
what is going yeah and I was and I was
like I just have to kill and try and
make all these people love me and was
just going really fast so I started
moving through the clubs quickly and he
just stuck to it stuck to it and
perfected it now he's you know he's
gigantic
yeah it really is it really is it a true
example of believing in yourself and
what you're doing
he wasn't wavering he had no idea where
he was going but he just stuck to a nose
yeah yes I just saw someone showed me an
old tape like you want to see Sebastian
bombing I'm like what yeah and it's like
basically the same thing but it's just
he hadn't quite figured it out yeah yeah
just came off like this super
pretentious dude you're like funny
yeah just weird and and and he just
stuck to it and then it just kind of
like all start to gel and it becomes
like this really unique thing it's like
I'm sure like people like that like
Maria Bamford I'm sure it was bombing
for years right I'm sure had to and
they're so funny yeah and so brilliant
so funny so it's but anyway that was
kind of our thing and Giraldo was like
somewhere in the middle you know he was
just running a hundred miles an hour and
so smart
yeah yeah yeah there was no in the
beginning I was a I I'd started for like
a year or two and then the girl I was
with her father died and I left cuz I
stopped doing Stan because I felt like I
didn't you know you got a more like to
take care of her and make money and I do
the right thing and so I put it down for
a little
a year maybe two rather would call me
like what are you doing work some money
you have like a regular job or you do I
was doing an advertising okay and the
small ad agency I gained 30 pounds I was
really heavy my hair was really long
yes really long and curly and I was
smoking weed every night yes
drinking beer every night playing uh
playing see you Maki with my friends so
you went for the comedian lifestyle you
just weren't doing calm I wasn't right I
was just depressed you got a great job
and they just went with that comedy life
yeah
brutal yeah it was brutal and I remember
I remember literally laying on my
sister's bed and saying am i funny
anymore
like what it'll drive you crazy being
around regular people and doing regular
stuff yeah and this was only doing
stand-up like in a little bit and
already I knew yeah that's where I
belong those are your people
yeah it's tough what like once you're
around comedians and like people who
think very differently than normal
people
it's it's draining like that's how it's
like being around normal people I'm just
like I can't be me if you are you you're
offending them yeah people and they just
think you're a lunatic yeah I was just
with my with the people that were in my
house just over this week and my
sister-in-law is very sweet love her to
death but very like takes everything
serious and you and I'm just like
blurting stuff out oh no
and my wife's like he's only this is
just so anyway I'm talking about the
straight guy so when I so then when I
came back there are tapes of me like if
you want to see papa bombing there's
there's me and like tight jeans heavy
tight jeans tucked in the hair and I was
going I would go a hundred miles an hour
because I was scared and I didn't want
them to
I didn't want to hear I would never like
wait for the laugh because I really care
yeah and I would lunge I would kind of
lean like with my maybe out like my bent
knee and like a straight leg behind it
and I would kind of lunge and like talk
like that and like this slow bizarre I
have some really great great old tapes
and I remembered Giraldo take me Dane
stole that that was pop of the fret and
I remembered sure I'll take me and I
froze one night on stage I was in the
middle of my act and I froze and I
couldn't remember what by the next joke
was just one of those moments you know
and I came back went out front of the
stand of New York and that was weird
they never happened before and draw the
kenai he's like you know you write
really good stuff I don't think you need
all that other I don't know if you need
to Lunger aggressive alpha Papa is not
necessarily but don't you feel like
there's different views like people meet
you in different time oh yeah I was just
at Rogen and I didn't have my glasses on
he's like whoa you going for a new look
and I'm like I've only been wearing
these glasses for like two years
like I never had glasses in my life and
but but all the people I met since yeah
I I used to wear a backwards hat always
right and when I stopped wearing it
people were freaked and up with you here
what are you going through something
like I just decided to stop wearing hats
I figured you were bald and I always had
the same shitty hair I have now but it
was just like all you'd see it's just
like the Dukes of Hazzard flip out
inside that's a good look I know exactly
and so the people be like yeah I assumed
you were balding the front no I just I'm
so lazy I literally haven't brushed my
hair in four years so being a guy that
carry that look around for a while yeah
what do you think's going what do you
think's going through judah friedlander
'he's head at this point Wow
I mean that's it I've only known Judah
as the world champ hat-wearing
yeah dude in many years ya know but it's
what I'm asking do you think there's
days where he's like I gotta wear it I
want to leave it home he probably does I
was so self-conscious about it at a
certain point because anytime I didn't
wear it which would be like ten times a
year everyone at The Comedy Store
because this was like the only place
where I ever perform then yeah everyone
a bit whoa what's up and I had a pretty
serious drinking problem too so I'd be
like six beers in a bit just very
confrontational you ever bring it back I
almost never wear a hat yeah yeah man I
will occasionally like if just one of
those days where I don't have time to
get prepared yeah it was them it was
that sweet mustache that I grew took me
for months but it eventually grew in
Nice and and it looked super creepy but
I started booking commercials always has
like the creepy loser that's great I met
my wife while I had a mustache the
moment I shaved it she was like thank
God there was like eight months in
relationship like I like she was like it
looks [ __ ] terrible
wow that's love what she was think did
you have an alter ego when you were
younger
no pretty consistent year old Irish
my god so you just like the Bremen's
there nine also really other other
comedian Brennan's other than Neil and
Kevin yeah no I don't think so there was
one who worked at the comic strip and he
was an actor yeah he was one of the
brothers and he was an actor very angry
on Twitter I only know him from Twitter
but I always hated his rage is he nine
kids that typewriter still he just
didn't have time for kids there's so
many Thai fried did you you are he just
had to get out of there
[Laughter]
the trick I was told I know the secret
already I already feel yeah in this
delicate flower yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
this wasn't right yeah I think there's a
lot of guys that I think rolls that
every guy Rosa that what a comedian we
watched if my wife was like I remember I
had a friend who was going off on the
side he was he seeing some girl on the
side and I remember him saying and
everything's cool I remember one point
he said that she's just the coolest like
she reads he wanted to he got that
doesn't plan was a terrible I regret
I never pull it out again one of them is
Neal Brennan I mean that a sitcom right
there yeah and they all have to live
with each other human mule was the first
a new it's like Neal Brennan
[Laughter]
Disney World I'm telling them tomorrow
at the audition by the way your Disney
World just so you know you bros
Disneyland you might have been first but
you're bigger slave style sunburned
sunburned bug bites it's amazing but I
think about that all the time like with
with my kids it's like you eat we order
him maybe like two or three times a week
you go out to eat you go on vacations
you do all this stuff it's like going
like to McDonald's was a huge deal going
out like we're ordering a pizza and it
was like whose birthday is it now it's
so common just do it yeah
I'm one of five kids and I remember like
people talk about like the fancy
restaurant they were going to was like
you know two kids whatever I'm back
we're not going there mom dad are paying
for seven people to eat at that place
way get called up the Pizza Hut we're
gonna get three large pizzas delivered
and devour it you feel like we were yeah
life and if there was ever like a party
or a reason that you did end up in that
restaurant your father was like no no no
not a venue you're not getting a steak
chicken ten kids travel every restaurant
moving tables together the wait staffs
like just family did I did alive there's
so many sitcom ideas podcast Life Guards
just hanging out
you have a callback for a commercial
first one for a call
let's call back well the first time it's
always just some guy who you will end up
seeing at the callback and he's just
operating a camera right so this guy's
gonna get the part probably because he's
deadly and calling himself back still
fun to hang out yeah he was all
promoting is promoting as a charity
benefit like an hour how long you been
in LA yeah no I never did I never met
Medina no I was working comedy magic
club I came out in in 2004 like 2002
2004 and I done a spot on Conan and the
people at NBC saw and asked if I had any
ideas for a show and then we started we
got I moved it along and got to do a
pilot with them so that started bringing
me out and that was 2004 and then we
were back and forth between
place in New York and just went back and
forth for years and we lived there solid
for like three in the middle of I kept
my place here and then we switched it
and did more here than there and just
went back and forth for a long time and
I just shut down New York like three
years ago and because you know once the
kids are bigger they want friends yeah I
want to stay in the same school yeah
they like their teachers and one point
my youngest was like you know I've been
the new kid every year yeah they're
having fun for a while but so then so
I've been solid here for like the last
three but I've been back and forth
forever so when I would first come out I
would do the improv and the comedy
magical of a lot fun Club it was fun and
traffic wasn't as bad as it is now like
literally in the time in just that time
from when I started coming out till now
it's like I would go down there no sweat
from Studio City like it's like you know
now it's an hour 10 at least to get down
there to do a spot as I live right I
live in Sherman Oaks right basically
where the 101 in the 405 meet right it's
a guaranteed hour
no matter what day it is yeah just I
mean I'm 40 feet from the on-ramp yeah I
get on that freeway then I just sit sit
and it's like brutal such a shame such a
good and it's fun yeah and when I first
moved to LA I moved out in 2002 right I
lived in Manhattan Beach because I came
from Kansas and I just figured by the
beach be by the beach it's all LA right
yeah yeah it was the worst that was like
the only convenient place and they would
never let me perform well I was terrible
so I can argue making but yeah
I got better I remember talking to the
manager and yeah sending near vales
whatever won't give me spots and if at
that point I lived up here that had two
blocks from here that's yeah oh yeah
I'll do it then it really is a shame I
mean so I was doing that for a long time
then
laughs factory in UCB for a while yeah I
was and I really liked that
Jamie's I really like Jamie he's a good
guy and uh and then it always tears me
down that's Jeremy yeah yeah started
coming here over the last company I'm
like I haven't even now it's here in
Largo mostly yeah and it's really fun
and very different
it really is totally different you know
the crowds are different the acts are
different ya know it's it's it's really
fun but it's but it's funny like all
that [ __ ] but he just kind of yeah
whatever's comfortable and you like at
that time I remember at one point I was
at UCB and Bob Odenkirk I was like I had
to run out to go do a laugh factory
spines like how would you go there yeah
it would be like used to be or Largo
kind of a guy and yeah really funny and
creative not such a great actor yeah
good but yes I just like bounce around
and this one really feels the most New
York to me like in New York the cellar
is where I would just work a single
night and like just there's they're just
running shows here every night and it's
not like oh this is the Asian kids night
and this is a special thing someone took
over the room for whatever right just
show every night how many show every
night it's just so comedian yeah it's
the only place in town
does that yeah put it somewhere else
yeah right right yeah well that's the
thing when you're hustling yeah I mean
that's that's why at times The Improv
would you know start doing it yeah and
it's a mistake though because the
audiences get trained they know if
they're coming here now that they're
gonna see a solid show every right and
professional can they use that Ustream
and they used to be the Improv was that
way for a long time
and once you chip away and start making
it an unreliable and predictable thing
you don't have that Allegiance the
people don't come yeah yeah though I
went there a month and a half ago and it
was awful there was one funny comic yeah
like six people you'll never see again
Hertz and that by the way they won't let
me perform on those shows either you
know just think about let me be one of
those terrible six once I get that
Popeyes credit that's Easy Street for me
that's good though when you the first
year but your or two of a child things
start happening for you because you how
magical tells told me that yeah so we'll
see true I baby comes with I did my
first yeah did his first TV appearance
I'm on the I'm dying up here yeah that
happened like a month and a half after
the kid was born weird and I didn't even
audition for that so the daily the pilot
I was talking about that brought me out
here from Sony and all that that was the
night that my daughter was born just the
name of my podcast now because the TV
show didn't last that long and it was
such a fun name I'm like humming to make
this into my podcast yeah it's good was
it was four episodes in the summer they
just burned it off after different
presidents changed and it was a whole
story 2006 probably yeah it's so much a
photo comes up so much nicer if you
don't see your weak expressionless you
just do the eyes up it's always a good
shot yeah it's like wow this guy's a
mess
I want more what's what am I not seeing
he must be having a good time or you
stories the creepy guy looking in a
window either way I like the logo but
the Instagram is yeah yeah you must have
some good haunted stories Todd that's
close to ghost stories I have he was
crazy ya know he was like he sold blowed
like Robin Williams and these guys in
the eighties he there's a head shot in
the front hall of the original room of
Robin Williams standing with some
uh-huh so one night I asked our guest
who's this guy in this photo he's like
oh that's the Todd I'm like who's the
Todd so he tells me this whole story
this guy's to sell below yeah he went
crazy
so he doesn't come around anymore so
then one night this I'm working the door
here that was my when I started here I
worked the door and this nice older lady
came up to the back which was already
out of place because at that point right
never we didn't have people in the shows
ever yeah and people who came around or
basically like not attics and like crazy
people just attracted to blinking lights
on a black building yeah and so this
there's a nice lady comes up to the back
door and she's like I'm looking for my
son
yes a beard he used to be a comic here
he has some mental problems now but
usually when he runs off gets lost
sometimes he shows up here yeah I was
like I haven't seen anyone so then a
little little later Don Barris shows up
and he's like yeah so I was hanging out
with Todd and we were at a me ba and the
next thing you know he had ran off I
don't know where he went it was like
okay so don't really think anything of
it just like it's fun Don's hanging out
with the crazy guy yeah and he escaped
basically it was the yeah the plot and
so then about four hours go by and we
close up and part of it my duty was to
go turn the power off the switchboards
in the main room so I go back to the
fuse box whatever in the green room and
I walk open the door lights are all out
and I turn the light on
there's just a dude standing in the
corner facing the corner I just freaked
out running out of there I go the man
herself Xander is this guy Dean at the
time he's like paulie's buddy for school
[ __ ] crazy guy
I hope it's Todd it's the only
explanation that isn't gonna end with me
murdered so we go back in there and he's
just still standing in there just like
to come on
five minutes ago bye so then we know
it's all Todd's mom and what's so scary
about that story is that it shows how
sick we all are in a way because like he
goes crazy his mental problems gets a
lobotomy and his brain is like I have to
go back go to the comedy store I know I
have it's the only it's too good to tell
but he's do it they'll still accept me
they I saw the thing on ours on HBO and
this guy was like a clown and he would
do like he had a little TV show and then
he became like a live clown at like
birthday parties and stuff and he's
losing it he's in his 80s and he's and
everyday is around 4 o'clock the Sun
starts going down a little bit he starts
getting ready for his show he hasn't had
a show in years he starts getting his
things and talking to his wife going
over a set list yeah I think I might try
this one tonight and she has it all
together yeah yeah good for you honey I
think they'll love that many stupid just
like us with the setlist yeah getting
ready and then she would just walk him
into his bedroom laying on the bed and
he'd go to sleep but you're just so used
to doing spots all the time yeah mine is
walking around sunset yeah it's dark
pretty close to midnight I should
probably head to the comedy store that's
am I gonna go yeah you know what
probably have a spot the main room
tonight I see all the lights turned off
I'll just go backstage and get ready
[Music]
it's so weird like people always say
like when they see the pictures in the
hallway of like oh my god it's so scary
like what happened there's a story
behind everybody everyone is went crazy
[Music]
[Laughter]
every time I see Barry so Bulls photo
I'm just haunted when we do and they
were really high and they were really
high
I've never met anyone who has I saw a
ghost sober story everyone it's always
like and there is a hundred percent
spirits there and you could you could
feel him and I was on so much blow it's
great yeah hold on you were feeling the
energy were you okay do you do you have
twitter all that stuff on Tom pop on
Twitter and an Instagram look and come
to pop as my podcast that's every week
and then I also do these live shows come
to Papa which is like a Prairie Home
Companion kind of a show I do that once
a month and that comes out unserious and
the podcast so yeah I'm glad it finally
worked out yeah yeah yeah great and back
again you can always hang out down here
if you want to get away some people they
have this I'm not kidding when I say
this is more comfortable waiting for a
spot than up there that's true I up
there have to pretend to be reading my
notes but you won't talk to me just burn
bridges that's that's how I stay away
thanks for listening guys I'm breaking
up cover the company store bye guys